[Music]
go
[Music]
[Music]
you know what a courtesy tap this young
man it sounds like this it's light
friendly I'm sure that's what your mom
meant to do no it's not mom
having a kind of a hard time lately I'm
sorry
[Music]
accept my apology Signori if you could
just do the same we could press recess
don't have anything to apologize for
[Music]
can you go face
ma'am are you okay I'm pretty sure the
guy in that trucks following me
he's road-raging watch this chill man go
your own way
I don't think you really know what a bad
day is
she will find out
that man stole my phone Eddie I'm
sitting here I'm waiting for you whose
phone is on across me friend
hey listen to me he's not a friend okay
he's a psycho who came after me today
this is where your first lesson begins
no I can't do that
[Music]
I need you to learn what a bad day
really is I need you to learn how sorry
yeah you're gonna learn to fine on some
retribution sounds like you're waking up
quiet awake
you better bring your A game
you're gonna need it
you
you